belle fois avec bon courage un directeur
technique très occupé après la fois il
faut superviser le démontage la soir
c'était une ruche
après la foule des visiteurs c'était la
pleine action de nos cinq six mille
exposants qui étaient sur le départ
une course contre la montre cet éleveur
de volailles et ses associés se sont
donnés une demi journée pour démonter
leurs stands mais vitesse ne veut pas
dire précipitation n'est pas question de
jeter la moindre planches stands on l'a
créée il ya trois ans avec mes collègues
non non on va tous leur mise et lampe il
est éventuellement faire des
modifications parce qu'on s'aperçoit
qu'il faut faire évoluer aussi le
restaurant pour l'option redémarrer
l'année prochaine leurs bêtes en place
rollier place pourtant des déchets il y
en a près de 120 tonnes à chaque fois
ici depuis plusieurs années un système
de tri sélectif a été mise en place
quinze tonnes de verre sont ainsi
collectés et recyclés papier carton et
bois connaissent également une seconde
vie mais comme pour les autres salons et
foires de france le gros point noir
reste le recyclage des trente mille
mètres carrés de moquette utilisé sur
l'événement aujourd'hui la moquette ne
bénéficie pas d'un système de recyclage
donc malheureusement c'est la seule
c'est la seule contrainte mais on a un
traitement anti feu qui nous est imposé
par la réglementation et c'est ce qui
fait que nous ne sommes pas en mesure de
recycler
une enquête à ce jour les équipes
techniques vont encore travaillé pendant
plusieurs jours pour faire place nette
le palais des expositions devra être fin
prêt dès vendredi pour le salon
studyrama